HADLEY WICKHAM: So I am
really so thrilled
to introduce our next keynote
speakers, Martin Wattenberg
and Fernanda Viegas, because
Martin and Fernando, I believe,
are really two of
the top visualization
researchers in the world today.
I have been a follower of
their work for over 10 years.
Chances are you have seen
some of their work before.
In fact, if you've ever
looked up
the definition of
a word on Google
and seen a little
line chart, I believe
that is Martin's most
popular, or most well-seen
visualization.
One of my personal
favorites is the wind map--
really beautiful
visualization of dynamic
wind currents over
the continental US.
If you google wind map--
fantastic, fantastic
visualization.
But recently,
Fernanda and Martin
have been working on
using visualization
to display really
complex ideas and
unpack many of the tools
of modern machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
So please join me in
welcoming Fernanda and Martin.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Thank you.
MARTIN WATTERNBERG:
Thank you, thank you.
So yeah, thank you so much.
Want to talk a little bit
about what we're doing now,
because it combines
both the visualization--
which has been our bread
and butter for a while--
with AI.
We are co-leads with Jeff
Holbrook of a group at Google
called PAIR--
stands for People
plus AI Research.
And before saying
anything more about it,
I want to quickly put up
pictures of the people
in the team, because I want to
emphasize that everything we're
talking about today-- this was
all very much a team effort,
and these people deserve credit.
The mission of PAIR is
to make machine learning
and artificial intelligence
productive, enjoyable,
and fair.
And we do that in various
ways, and one of which--
I'm happy to say,
actually, we've
released a fair number of
open-source tools, which
we'll talk about today.
We also create
educational materials,
academic publications, and do
a lot of public work as well.
Now, you might ask, why are
we talking about human-AI
interaction at this conference?
And there's sort of a snarky
answer you could give,
which is that some might say
is just fancy statistics.
And maybe there's
some truth to that.
But there's a more
serious answer,
which is that you, as
people who analyze data,
you have a lot of power,
and you know that.
But you might have even more
power than you realize--
that, as AI becomes more
and more pervasive,
it's turning out
the data analysis
is very much the key
to getting AI right.
FERNANDA VIEGAS:
So to start with, we're going
to start at the beginning.
We have a few projects we'd
like to share with you,
and one of them is about just
visualizing training data.
I'm sure you all know this,
that a big part of what
goes into these massive machine
learning systems is the data.
And you need to be super careful
and mindful about the data.
And yet, when we talk with
engineers-- software engineers
about some of the problems
that come up in these systems,
their first instinct tends
to be to debug their program.
And so our favorite motto
is, debug your data first,
not your program.
And this is something
of a learning curve.
And I think you all are
way ahead of the engineers,
but one of the realities
is that we need tools
for dealing with the
huge amounts of data
that these people are using.
And so we're still
working on that.
One example of a
tool we created,
which is a visualization
for just training data--
I'm going to demo that
with one of the hello world
data sets of machine learning,
which is called CIFAR-10.
And all it is-- it's
a bunch of images,
squared little images of 10
different classes of things.
Each image has just one main
object or entity inside of it.
And the entire data set
has been human labeled
in these 10 different classes.
So you have deer, you have
a car, you have automobile,
and so forth.
And another thing that's
important about this data set
is that, because it is one
of the hello world data
sets of machine learning,
it is used everywhere.
It is used as a benchmark.
It's been used by thousands
of people all over the world,
and it's used in
publications as well.
How do I get--
Maybe that X.
Let's get to the demo.
OK, cool.
So this is our
little visualization,
and it's called Facets.
And all I'm doing
here is visualizing
the images I have just
by the different classes.
So as far as data
visualization goes,
it's extremely straightforward.
I can zoom in.
I can look at
images very closely,
if I want to, see how
pixilated they are, and so
forth-- nothing super special.
You can see the
labels of the classes,
and you can also see
that, if I accidentally
click on any one of the
images, it brings up
a little card at
the very top there
with the metadata about
each one of these images.
So far, nothing special--
but even this is hard
for regular engineers
using machine learning
systems to get to see.
They don't usually get to
see their training data.
And the reason why--
I'm sure you all realize--
why you want to do something
like this is because it could
be that half of your
data set is just empty,
is just blank images.
Or even worse than that,
it could be the just one
of your classes is
blank, and nothing else.
And so you want to be able
to just very quickly play
with your data and look at it.
Once we have this, we
can play little games.
So I can look at the
same visualization,
but I can now
distribute it by hue.
And I can see that there
are different bulges
in different classes.
So I can see that
airplane at the very top
and ship towards the
bottom are the classes
with the most blue images.
That kind of makes sense.
I'm taking photos against
the sky or against the water.
And then all of my animal
classes in the middle-- bird,
cat, deer--
they tend to hang out
more on the earthy tones.
OK, so far, so good.
Now, I can do other things.
I can say, now show
me a confusion matrix.
A confusion matrix
is basically me
trying to understand
how in sync humans
and my machine learning
system really are.
So everything on
the column there
are the labels that have been
manually given to these images
by humans, and
everything at the top
are the labels that my
system is giving, as it
tries to classify these images.
So the good news for
me is that the diagonal
is by far the most populated
set of cells I have there,
because that's where
humans and machine agree.
So that's great.
But then other things
they can do with this--
I can say, OK, so
now let's filter out
all the correct guesses.
I'm going to filter
out that diagonal.
And then immediately,
I have all the mistakes
that my system is making.
And I can see an
interesting pattern here.
I can see that my
most populated cell--
or couple of cells--
over here and over here--
is the intersection
between cats and dogs.
My system is kind of confused
So it could be that, at
this point, I go back
and give my system more
examples of cats and dogs
so we can retrain, and hopefully
get better at these classes.
This could be one
of the things I do.
All right, another thing I
can do with this visualization
is look at the softmax label.
So towards the
end of my network,
I want to understand not only
how these images are being
classified by my
system, but I also
want to understand
how sure my system is,
how certain my system is
of any of those classifications
it makes.
So the way to read this is, the
more an image is to the right,
the more certain my system
is that that is indeed
a dog, or a cat, or an airplane.
And everything-- the more to the
right, the more correct it is.
On the contrary, the more
to the left you have--
these over here-- the
more certain my system
is that that is not a
cat or not an airplane.
And those are incorrect
classifications.
So one of the things
that I want to do here
is I might want to go-- we
became interested-- we're like,
oh wow.
But check it out.
Cats is still very
populated here.
There's a bunch of cats my
system is very, very sure
are not cats.
So we zoomed in and
started looking like, wow,
what do these cats look like,
that my system just-- very
certain aren't cats?
And again, think back that
this is a benchmark data
set used by lots of
people all over the world.
We started looking at
this, and we're like,
there's totally a thing
there that's not a cat.
Can anyone spot-- it's on
the second row to the bottom,
over here.
My system is very
sure that's a frog.
And so am I. And
yet, it has been
labeled by humans as a cat.
So what is our little
tale telling us here?
The same tale as usual--
you have to go back to
your data and look at it.
And there are going
to be mistakes.
And if you can't look
at it in an easy way,
you're going to continue to see
these mistakes over and over
again.
So this was a tool that we
started using internally,
and then decided
this is actually
a simple, straightforward tool
that's actually super useful.
And we decided to open-source--
so Facets is a open-source tool
available for anyone.
And yes, I know that
you can do this in R.
And I'm sure that a lot of
you are doing it already--
slice and dicing-- simple stuff.
But there is a lot of
people who don't use R too,
and so having something
on the web is also useful.
All right, the next thing
we want to talk about
is this notion
that, as soon as you
start feeding these massive data
sets to these machine learning
systems, you are going
to be talking about bias
and skews in your data set.
And as soon as you start
deploying these systems
in the world, you
are going to be
faced with fairness questions.
These are very complex issues.
It's not like you have
a technical solution
for these things,
but there is also
a technical piece to trying
to solve some of these things.
So Martin and I we're
interested in whether we
could use very simple data
visualization to start
illustrating some
of the trade-offs
that you have to make, when you
start thinking about fairness
in machine learning.
As I introduce this
visualization--
it's very simple--
we're going to play
a little game here,
which is we are going to
imagine that we are a bank
and we're deciding who
we're going to give loans to
and who we're going
to not give loans to.
So each one of these
dots is a person
who comes to our bank
asking for a loan.
They have a credit score.
All of these things
are imaginary.
My credit score
goes from 0 to 100.
And their location is--
reflects their credit score.
Each one of the light colored
dots would default on our loan.
All of the dark colored
dots would pay us back.
So in other words,
we want to give loans
to the dark colored
dots, and we do not
want to give loans to
the light colored dots.
Many people come to our bank.
We set a threshold.
Below that threshold,
we don't give loans.
Above that threshold,
we give loans.
So far, so good--
except that, in reality,
life is not that simple.
So no matter where
I put my threshold,
chances are I'm going
to be denying loans
to people who would pay me back,
and I would be giving loans
to people who default.
And so this is still
a simplification
of the real world, but
it's a distribution
that starts to look a
little bit more realistic.
And you can see that, no matter
where you put your threshold,
you're going to make
incorrect guesses.
Then the next question
becomes, well,
you may have different
populations of users coming--
people coming to your
bank and asking for loans.
And you may know that
these distributions
are different for
these different people.
How are you going to be fair?
Now that you have
a blue population
and an orange population
with different distributions,
how are you going to
decide how to be fair?
And there are many different
ways you can do this.
So let me just show you the
little demo/visualization
we created.
This accompanies,
by the way, a paper
on machine learning fairness.
So basically, we just created
this little simulation here,
which is kind of what you
had been seeing before.
And it's interactive,
and I can play with it.
And you can see what
happens underneath,
as I'm changing the
threshold here at the top.
At the bottom, you
can see the percentage
of incorrect and
correct guesses I make.
You can also see
things at the bottom--
here are these
pie chart things--
they stand for the positive
rate of loans they give.
So in other words,
of all the people
who come to my bank, what
is the percentage of people
I give loans to?
And then there is another
pie chart that says--
sorry-- the positive
rate is on the right,
true positive rate
is on the left.
True positive rate means, of all
the people who come to my bank
and would pay me back,
what is the percentage
of people I give loans to?
So I can play with this stuff.
I can play with
them independently.
And the other thing I want to
make sure, because I'm a bank,
is I want to make a profit
at the end of the day.
So how do I do these things,
and still, how can I be fair?
So we put some presets
here at-- on the left.
One is, if you don't
want to be fair at all,
click on maximum profit.
There it is.
That's what your
thresholds should be,
given the distributions.
If you do want to be fair,
maybe what you want to do
is you want to be group unaware.
So I clicked on Group
Unaware, and you
can see that what
this means is I
have the same thresholds
for both populations.
So I don't care if you're blue.
I don't care if you're orange.
You're going to be treated
the same because, that's
the most fair thing--
that's the fair thing to do.
That could be,
except that when we
start looking at the
positive rates here,
I can see that, of all the
people who pay me back--
the blue people--
I give loans to 81%
of them, versus only
60% of the orange people.
Is that fair?
Well, maybe the next
thing you could try
is something called
demographic parity.
And demographic parity optimizes
for the same positive rate.
So of all the blue and
all the orange people
who come to my
bank, I try to give
the same percentage of loans.
Again, what this
means is my thresholds
are different-- quite different
for these different groups.
Is that fair?
Maybe, maybe not-- the
last thing here I have
is equal opportunity,
which optimizes
for a true positive rate.
So anyway, long
story short, there
are many different ways
to think about being fair.
And how do you translate
those values into math
for deciding in a
scenario like this?
The point of doing this
was that Martin and I
were interested if, with a
very simple abstract scenario
like this, with a simple
visualization that people
could just play with--
if they could start to
develop a certain intuition
for the trade-offs that happen
when you're actually trying
to decide this on a system.
And it was interesting to see
that this simple visualization
went kind of viral on the web.
And we started seeing people
have these really interesting
discussions of,
oh, wow, I always
thought that demographic
parity was the way to go,
but now I see that--
whatever-- equal opportunity
is maybe a more interesting way
to think about fairness.
And just to be clear, there
are many, many more metrics
of fairness that have
come up since then also
in the literature.
And I think that's
not going to stop.
Another part of the conversation
that we saw online, that
is, I think, very important,
is people realizing, oh,
and you can't have
all of these at once.
There is no perfect solution.
It's always a trade-off, and
you're going to have to choose.
And so we started
getting emails.
And so for instance,
one of the emails
we got was from a Criminal
Justice Department in the US,
saying, we saw
this visualization.
Do you think we could
create something
like this for our own department
so that we start to understand
what the trade-offs
are that we're making
with the systems we're using?
Obviously, we're
not a bank, but is
this-- this would be
a very powerful way
to have people in the department
engage with these questions.
And so based on this and
on the reaction we got--
let me go back--
we decided to go from
that toy simulation
to actually trying to put
together an actual tool that
allowed you to do some of this
playing around with your model
and with testing your model
for different scenarios.
And so this is a tool we
created called the What-If Tool.
And this is a code free,
probing tool
for machine learning systems
that allows you to test for
some of these scenarios--
to say things
like, oh, what if I
want demographic parity in the
different slices of my data?
What thresholds should
I use in my model?
It allows you to do things like
click on a data point and say--
for instance, let's go
back to the loan scenario--
and say, oh, this person
did not get a loan.
Let me go back to
the next slide.
Here-- this person
did not get a loan.
Who is the nearest person to
that one that did get a loan,
and what is the delta there?
So a little notion of
counterfactual, if you
will, without the causality--
that's a separate conversation--
but just this notion
of starting to try to understand
what's happening with these
systems, how they are behaving,
asking a bunch of alternative
scenarios, trying a
bunch of edge cases,
and also playing with
notions of fairness--
of how different slices
of your data set are doing
vis a vis one another.
This too is open-source, so
it is available for anyone.
It is also being integrated
into Google's Cloud AI
so that anyone
using that platform
can now play with these
alternative scenarios and test
things for themselves before
they decide to launch something
or to try to debug situations.
And I think one of the
really important things
here too is the
fact that we're not
expecting that you need to
be a PhD in machine learning
to ask these probing questions.
Many more people should be
engaging and experimenting
with the way these
systems behave.
MARTIN WATTENBERG:
So I think that
the story so far
is, you're seeing how
important data analysis is
in all of this.
And then I think, also, when
you look at machine learning
fairness, there's this
issue, number one,
that trying to make
the world better,
to try to do the right
thing involves statistics.
However, also, if you
are deploying models,
this is something you
now have to think about--
or should have been thinking
about all along, indeed.
And I think that's
an important change
of mindset for many
people that we've seen.
And again, statistics
is a key part of this.
There's something
else going on, though,
which is that,
using data analysis,
you can actually end up finding
new ways to control AI systems.
And to explain that,
we're going to take
a journey through
high dimensional space
to understand the super power.
So let's talk about
data in high dimensions,
and we're going to introduce a
couple of things in a row here.
Let's start with a warm up.
And for our warm up,
we're going to visualize
that another famous
hello world data set
from machine learning,
a data set of little 28
by 28 icons that represent
handwritten digits that
is often used to test a very
simple machine learning models.
And what we're
going to talk about
is how you can think
about each of these images
as a vector in high
dimensional space.
And the trick-- which is
familiar, I'm sure, to some,
if not many of you--
is that we look at the pixels
and we give them all values.
In this case, we'll say
black is 0, white is 1,
and intermediate values get
some floating point number.
And then we just list of values
of all the pixels in a row,
and that gives us a vector.
So for example,
this vector would
turn into something
that looks like that.
Other images would look--
turn into other vectors.
So why have we done this?
Well, this is going
to be our example data
set, as we look
at a visualization
that we call the
embedding projector.
Let's take a look.
All right, yes, so now
you see-- rotating.
You are looking at
784-dimensional space here.
What you are actually
saying, of course,
is a two-dimensional projection
of a three-dimensional view
of this high
dimensional space that
is using principal component
analysis to project
these linearly.
And that's definitely
an interesting thing,
but it also is
kind of a big blob.
As much of one can
ooh and ah over this,
it's a little bit
hard to make sense of.
So let's take another view.
Let's look at a different
way of looking at this.
OK, now we're using
a method called
a UMAP that is designed to
take high dimensional space,
and instead of using
a linear projection,
it's using a nonlinear
projection that
has many complicated
properties, which
we'll talk about in a moment.
But the basic idea is that
it-- one thing it does
tend to preserve is clustering.
And so one thing that I can do
is, since this is our data set
and we have labels,
I can label--
I can color these
digits by their label.
And that lets us easily see,
for example, that in general,
all the 1's are
at a certain area,
all the 4's are in another
area, and so forth.
But we can also say it doesn't
completely get it right.
This 3, it clearly
thinks, belongs
with the 2's, this 8 looks
like a 2, and so forth.
Already I think this
view can tell you
a bunch of interesting things.
One thing is just that,
apparently, these digits are
actually pretty well-separated.
You can see why this is not the
hardest machine learning task
in the world-- that there
is just a natural clustering
structure that is--
even a visualization method
brings it out pretty well.
One other thing that's
kind of nice, though,
is that, if you look even
within these clusters,
you can start to see some
interesting structure.
For example, in
these 1's, you'll
notice that they're
kind of tilted
to the left on this side.
They're tilted to the
right on this side.
And you really can
start to get a sense
of what the geometry looks like
in this high dimensional space.
Let's see.
I want to go back there.
What else can we do with
high dimensional space?
Well, let's see.
I think, if there's
time at the end,
we might I talk a little
bit about what these mean,
but I think I might skip this.
I will say that, among
the educational materials
that we've been putting out are
step-by-step interactive essays
about how to interpret
these complicated nonlinear
projections, because
they're amazing, but weird.
And the weirdness can be your
friend, but you have to--
FERNANDA VIEGAS: And
sometimes problematic, so you
want to be aware of that.
Yeah.
MARTIN WATTENBERG:
OK, so another kind of word
in high dimensional object,
which turns out to
be very, very useful,
is something called
a word embedding.
So word embedding-- it's
sort of weird terminology,
but what it just means
is you're mapping words
into points in high
dimensional space, much the way
we mapped those images.
However, with images, there was
a pretty straightforward way
of doing it by using pixels.
With words, it's actually
sort of complicated.
And I won't get into
exactly how that is done.
There are actually a
couple of different ways,
and the interesting
thing is they
often pretty similar
results, if you do it well.
The idea is usually to make
sure that related words end up
in near each other.
And in fact, it turns
out you can do this.
However, when people figured
out ways to make that happen,
they discovered a really
interesting and surprising
fact, which is not only can
you get a situation where
similar words are
near each other,
but almost as a byproduct--
seemingly as an accident--
you get meaningful
directions in space.
And so the image that
you're seeing here
is a figure from one very
famous early paper in which they
showed that there's a direction
in space that corresponds
to the relationship of
a capital to the country
it is a capital of,
which is really amazing.
OK, so let's take a look--
just because we have
our visualization up--
of what those word
embedding is look like.
And I'm going to show
this in a couple of ways.
This is just a raw PCA view.
This is a UMAP view.
And let's actually play
with us a little bit.
Let us explore this,
because I think
it really gives a sense of--
you're seeing the
English language here.
This is the geometry of English.
And what can we say about it?
Well, there's obviously clumps.
Let's go spelunking
a little bit.
What is this clump here?
Oh, look, a bunch of names--
seems like largely
maybe boys names here.
And then let's see.
We get some other names--
FERNANDA VIEGAS: It might
be hard for people--
MARTIN WATTERNBERG:
Yeah, I'll read them--
Lloyd, Alex, Matt, Joel.
What about this cluster here?
Horns, percussion,
guitar, quartet, bass--
we found the music
cluster over there.
What about these?
Oh, look, we have some numbers.
Oops-- let's see if we
can zoom in on them.
0, 1, 2, 3--
we can actually see-- and in
fact, if we zoomed in more,
we can almost see a little
bit of a linear structure
representing those.
We have some other things here.
Let's see-- infinity,
angle, math---- look,
we found the tech world here.
So there really is everything.
And this gives you a sense
of just how much information
is encoded here.
But now I want to show one
more thing, and that is--
let's do something tricky.
Let's do a custom embedding.
And the way this
works is we actually
can define an axis in terms
of one word to another word.
Right now, it's just a 2D
projection, it's linear,
and both axes are random.
But let's actually search
for a word and look
at some neighbors.
Let's see, what's a good one?
How about science?
I'll click on this.
We'll isolate those 100 points.
And now, we can see the
neighbors of the word science
in PCA.
But now let's actually
do a custom thing.
And we can play this little
game where, say, we look at--
let's look at man on the
left and woman on the right.
And suddenly, we see
something really interesting--
that now, the left right of
the x-axis, left to right,
has things that
it's thinking closer
to the word man versus woman.
And this is actually
a little bit sad
that you can technical is
it's most male word here
in this neighborhood.
And meanwhile, on
the female side,
although we do a scientist, we
see religion, author, story,
psychology.
And this is actually
a sobering moment.
When people started to realize
this about these embeddings,
I think they just realized how
serious things had become--
that these things had been
trained on huge corpora
of existing words,
language, and those had
contained a bunch of biases.
And this new word embedding
was very efficiently
encoding some of those.
So in fact, we can show a
couple of other examples.
This is the neighborhood
of engineers--
shows many of the
similar things.
If you do a neighborhood
pf math..
FERNANDA VIEGAS: You might
want to read it out loud.
MARTIN WATTERNBERG: Yeah.
You can see geometry,
computational on the man side--
again, psychology, art,
library on the woman side.
And it's not even just the
big famous biases, like gender
or something, but you can--
even something
like old and new--
and not with people, you
can see interesting things
that are meaningful, like
with-- if I put in a book
and look at its neighbors,
I see-- for old,
I see things like
poem and manuscript.
On the new side, I see
company, for instance-- magic.
And you can start to
see it's picking up
on important associations,
but in a way that
is potentially problematic.
So we have this
thing that is powerful.
It requires a lot of analysis.
But let's think
about how we could
use this idea of meaningful
directions in other ways,
now that we have it.
So one way, it turns
out, is to interpret
what's going on inside
of neural networks
so that they're not,
in fact, black boxes.
And I'd like to very quickly
fly through a method called
TCAV, published in ICML 2018.
And the idea behind
this method is
to take this insight that, OK,
if things like word embeddings
have directions that
correspond to things that
are meaningful to humans, like
capital cities to capitals,
maybe there are other
types of embeddings
that have that same
property, and we
can use that to our advantage.
So I'll illustrate this by
imagining a question you might
ask of an image classifier.
Let's say it looks at
a picture of a zebra,
and you wonder, why did it
think that thing was a zebra?
So there's sort of a bad
answer to this question
and a good answer.
The bad answer is if it
told you something like,
it with this particular pixel
or these sets of pixels,
because that's not--
those are not terms that
a human could understand.
A much better answer would be if
it could say something like, it
was striped, and that helped.
Of course, it's very
hard to figure out
how to extract that answer.
However, there is
a way to do it.
So let's follow
what happens, if you
have a neural network
that is recognizing
an image, like zebra.
So you put in an image--
let's say it's an
image of a zebra--
and then it will--
you put it into a neural
network, and what is shown here
is a little cartoon of
one famous network called
Inception.
And the idea is that, in this
kind of network, you have--
the image get transformed
layer by layer.
You think of each layer as
performing a transformation
of Euclidean space.
For if you put something
like zebra through it--
showed an image--
in each of these
layers, you can think
of the state of the layers
as a set of activations
of the neurons, and
those activations
form a vector in high
dimensional space.
So you can see how this starts
to relate to what we were just
looking at.
And then what's
interesting is, if you
put a whole bunch
of images through,
you get a bunch of points in
this high dimensional space.
And you can start
playing this game
with meaningful directions.
So let's show how this works.
So the idea is that,
let's say there's
a concept you're interested
in-- for example, stripes
or the presence of stripes.
You don't even have
to try to define
to the computer in
language what stripes is.
You could just show it a bunch
of examples of striped images.
And then you put
those striped images
through your neural
network, and then--
FERNANDA VIEGAS:
And one important thing--
these are not images of zebras.
This is just any
stripes anywhere.
MARTIN WATTENBERG:
We've done this literally
with striped ties,
and striped shirts,
and abstract stripes.
That's a good point.
And then what you'll
get is a cluster
the images in this
space of activations
in an intermediate layer
that represents stripes.
And then you can also put a
bunch of random other images
through, and train a
classifier to distinguish
between the stripes
and the non-stripes.
And that gives you what's
called a concept activation
vector, a direction in space
that represents a concept.
And then, this is
what's cool, is
that you can start
calculating with that.
That vector is something--
you can, for example, take
directional derivative to
understand the sensitivity
to this concept.
So computers like it,
but humans like it too,
because it's a human-friendly
concept of stripes
that they're getting
an answer in terms of.
So this turns out to actually
be a very useful technique
in general.
There's a lot more we
can say, but what's
really interesting
is that you can
go from just interpreting
or understanding directly
to control.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: Yeah.
So imagine that you start with
this super high dimensional
space, and you find
meaning in that space--
meaning that is also
meaningful to humans.
So what I want to
show you next is
an example of a project where
we used that for health care.
So here's the scenario.
We were working with
pathologists trying
to diagnose cancer,
and the way they work
is they will look at
a slide of a patient--
very much like the large
image you see here--
and then they will try--
they will very, very closely
analyze this image and
try to understand, one,
do I believe there--
is there a cancer here?
And if so, what grade of cancer?
This is what's called Gleason
1, Gleason 2, Gleason 4.
And so even though there has--
there is an extensive set
of work that has been done with
optimizing algorithmic trends--
performance to try to look
at an image like this
and say, yes, there
is cancer, no, there
is no cancer, much
less attention
had been paid to actually, what
kind of information and what
kind of interactions
would doctors
like to get out from a
dialogue with these systems?
Instead of just being given
a number and a probability,
do they actually want
to interact and direct
these systems?
It turns out that, yes,
they would like to do this.
And part of the reason why
they want to do stuff like this
is because, many times,
for things like--
sometimes there are
defects in these images,
and they want to
say, dismiss that.
I don't want you to pay
attention to that thing.
That's not important.
Or there are anatomical features
that they care deeply about--
things like the
density of glands,
or whatever other concept.
And think about it.
Those are high level concepts.
How do you tell the machine
what I really care about
or how dense the
glands are here?
So you can you can do
things that have been done.
We're going to talk about this.
But basically, what
we did is we created
a set of tools that
allowed pathologists
to very quickly navigate
these highly massive data
sets, because
again, what they're
trying to do-- they're
looking at that slide
and they are trying
to get the system
to bring to them the
nearest neighbors.
What is the patient
I've seen before that
has been diagnosed--
what is the closest case to
this case I'm seeing now?
But that's not a one-shot thing.
That is the thing
that's interesting.
It's not just like,
automate that.
So one of the things is just
allowing people to cut little--
to just say, focus here.
That's what I want to do.
Things like these
have been done before.
Or once you bring
me a bunch of cases
that are like the case I
just highlighted for you,
now let me go deeper into one
of those cases and bring me more
closest neighbors
to those cases.
So in other words, let
me navigate by example.
I want you to pay
attention to this now.
Now, let me go back.
I want you to pay
attention to-- oh,
this is interesting--
let's go that way.
All of that kind of
had been done before.
The thing that's
new that we can do
is now, with things like CAVs,
that you just heard about,
we can actually create much
more sophisticated ways
of navigating these systems
in medical concepts.
So working with
the pathologists,
they told us that a medical
concept they deeply care about
is something called stroma.
I'm not a doctor.
I had no idea what this
was, but for them, it
was super interesting.
So we created a
slider where they
could say, show me cases like
this, but with more stroma,
or with less stroma--
or fused glands.
That's another medical concept
they care deeply about.
And so because, again,
these ML systems--
inside these highly
massive spaces,
there are meaningful
directions, we
were able to map
these medical concepts
to these meaningful
directions in the system,
and that gave doctors a
much more powerful way
of interacting with the systems.
And one of the really
important things
here is to actually--
for the doctor,
to calibrate their trust.
Should I trust this?
Should I not trust this?
Or even to learn how the system
works-- how does it behave?
How does it think
about edge cases?
And so we actually
had a user study--
in this case, was
with 12 pathologists--
looking both at a traditional
machine learning system
that just gives you a prediction
with a confidence level,
or at this system
called SMILY, where
you have all these
different tools
that you can interact with.
And the results
were very positive.
Basically, they-- all 12
pathologists preferred SMILY.
The level of trust was
significantly higher.
And even though you would think,
if you could only automate
my work for me, I'd be done,
they actually found a lot
of use in going back and
forth-- but not only that--
steering the system in
ways that they cared about.
MARTIN WATTERNBERG: Yeah, I
think what you see from this
is the ability of
statistical analysis
to actually help
steer these systems.
And I want to talk to
another aspect of this.
And so here, I'm going
to ask you to actually do
some imagining here,
and even answer
some questions in your head.
So the situation
is, imagine you're
a company or
nonprofit-- whatever.
You're designing a
system to recommend books
to library patrons.
And let's imagine you have
a team of people doing this.
And you have engineers.
Maybe have someone who is
responsible for the design.
And I mean that broadly, in
terms of user experience,
or UX, as people say.
And you're going over a
bunch of the big decisions
and small decisions that
you'll have to make,
and which ones do you need to
consult that user experience
designer on?
And so let's just go through
some questions, and I will--
you can think about this.
Does the system show one
recommendation or many?
What hardware does it run on?
Just answer these in your head.
Do users see an explanation
for recommendations?
Which database to
store your metadata in?
When should you
bother that designer?
What typeface do we use
for recommendations?
Do we use this particular
loss function--
which I will not read out loud?
It's tech.
Do we allow users to
like a recommendation,
and should our L2
regularization constant be 9.83?
So you might have
some answers in mind.
Some, I think, are
actually kind of obvious.
Clearly, you should talk
to your designer about
whether you show one
recommendation or many.
They should be involved in that.
I think some are not
really design issues,
like what database you
use to store metadata.
Their time is precious.
They don't need to
weigh in on that.
However, there is one
weird question here,
which is the loss function.
And we would argue
that, in many cases,
this may be the most important
UX decision of all, which
seems very counterintuitive.
Why would a chunk of math
be a user experience issue?
And the answer is
that, essentially,
in a machine learning
system, your loss function
expresses the goal of
what your system is doing.
And that goal
exactly what
happens in practice,
that tells you
whether people are
more likely to see
bad recommendations
or good ones,
are they going to see
similar ones or diverse--
or more diverse ones, and
many, many other aspects.
We see this anywhere
recommendation systems
are used.
And that's, again, kind
of a sobering thought,
because how do you
understand this thing?
Can a mathematician
just stare at it
and figure out the effects?
No.
But a statistician,
you've got a good chance.
If you look at pilot tests,
user practice, run simulations,
you've got a whole bunch
of tools to look at.
And so what this says, I
think, in the new world
that we find
ourselves in with AI,
is that statisticians have an--
anyone who works with data has
an incredibly important role
to play.
The models that you create
are having broad effects
on all sorts of people.
As you think about
what stakeholders,
who you want to take care
of, think about also,
who you want to talk to.
Like, as you're writing a
formula for your loss function,
maybe you should talk
to a UX designer.
As you do that,
get their opinion.
That could be as good a
moment for a user test
or ethnography as
any other moment
in the design of the system.
You have a lot of power.
FERNANDA VIEGAS:
[LAUGHS] And so even
though traditionally,
design may have looked
like this, right,
with the colors and the values,
we believe that in the current
era of machine learning,
design is both of these things.
It needs to be.
We need to start thinking
that way, we believe.
And so basically, our thought
to leave you with today
is that if you work an R or
with data or with ML code,
you are part of the
user experience team,
whether or not you know it.
And you have a lot of
power, as Martin was saying.
So think about that.
Think about how
you're going to bridge
between the world of data and
what you see in the models,
in the data logs you see, in
the data analysis you make,
and what the end user
experience is going to be,
because it's going to depend
more and more on this bridge.
And so just to leave
you with one resource,
hopefully that could be helpful.
This guidebook is something
PAIR launched last May.
And it's a set of
guidelines that
tries to be very concrete about
what does it mean to build
and ship AI -enabled products?
This is something that
took over 150 googlers
from all over the
company come together.
We also had academics
that we consulted with.
This came from a lot of
our internal experience
shipping AI-enabled products.
But this is something that
needs to be much, much bigger
than Google.
This is just the
beginning of trying
to go from those
very lofty goals,
like we need to make
machine learning fair.
We need to make machine
learning explainable to the, OK,
how do we get there?
How do we do this when
I have to ship a product
in the next three weeks?
So this is a quick view
of the different chapters
that the guidebook has.
It's full of samples do's and
don'ts on the user experience
side, step-by-step guidelines,
and also interactive
worksheets.
And the whole point
is that this is
going to take an entire
team to figure out.
This is not just the UXers
or the engineers or the data
scientists.
We're going to have to be
talking all of us together.
And you all hold a lot of
power in that conversation.
So that's it.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
HADLEY WICKHAM:
So I'm going to add a little
editorial voice to this.
[LAUGHS]
Anonymous asks, why are
you, as visualization experts,
using pie charts?
FERNANDA VIEGAS: [LAUGHS]
MARTIN WATTERNBERG: Don't
get me started on pie charts.
I think they are so underrated.
I actually think there are
many, many good aspects
of pie charts.
They, in cases where you have
only a few items, like three
or four, and where you're
interested in the sizes of sums
of wedges that are
next to each other,
I actually think they have many
advantages over bar charts.
There are certain
queries you can make.
Like, is there anything
that has a majority?
Or are there two that have them
slices of a majority compared
to a third or two others?
They're much easier.
If you look at the history
of research into pie charts,
people have been trying,
literally since the 1920s,
to prove that they're bad.
And they never really have.
[LAUGHS] Don't get me started.
Oops.
[LAUGHS]
HADLEY WICKHAM:
So we have quite a few
questions just about, like,
what tools did you use to
make these visualizations?
FERNANDA VIEGAS:
Oh, so most of the things you
saw today are JavaScript tools.
And we tend to code
things from scratch.
MARTIN WATTERNBERG: I
mean, D3 is very helpful.
I also think that WebGL
has been sort of amazing.
Like, that's been a
huge technical advance,
like that when I
think about what
has changed since when I first
started doing visualization,
there are things you can do,
just the number of images
you can animate at
one time smoothly.
That's been a big deal.
FERNANDA VIEGAS: One thing
that I think we forgot to say.
The embedding projector that
you saw Martin demo to date,
that's also open source.
That's also available.
And anyone can,
yeah, play with it.
HADLEY WICKHAM:
So I had a personal
question, which
is it looked like
one of those parts
is a ggplot2 plot.
Is that correct?
MARTIN WATTENBERG:
It probably is, actually, yes.
[LAUGHS]
HADLEY WICKHAM:
Taylor, asks, Facets
is a beautiful tool
for exploring image data.
What strategies do
you use when you've
got nonimage data, like
400 variables trying
to protect a class?
MARTIN WATTENBERG:
[SIGHS] So it depends
on the type of variable.
So we certainly do
a bunch of things.
And that idea of, like,
slicing and dicing, you usually
have to pick a couple of
variables to focus on.
There are a couple of things.
So one is, in many
cases, you can actually
use something, like the
embedding projector,
depending on the type of
variables to do clustering.
In other cases, I don't know
that we have a really good
solution to offer.
And, again, this is
exactly why I think you
the audience have
power is that there's
a wide opening for
you to actually make
a big difference in the
field by providing the tools.
HADLEY WICKHAM:
So Yim register asks, [INAUDIBLE]
is awesome for developers.
But are you also
thinking about pathways
for people affected
by these models
so they can self-advocate
for models that
about models that exclude them?
FERNANDA VIEGAS:
Yeah.
That's a very good question.
I think it's a very hard one.
One of the things
we're working on
is just AI literacy, in general.
So we are developing a number
of educational materials.
The visualization
you saw with fairness
was one of these moments
when we realized,
oh, these simple visualizations
actually have a lot of power
just to exactly that
start to educate people.
We want a much broader set
of folks to be critical
and to be engaged at a certain
level with this at a level
where they feel they know
what questions to ask
of the technology.
And so all of this
stuff that we work on,
we try to make it open source,
make it available publicly.
But I also think that creating
tools that are code-free
is extremely important
exactly to lower the barrier
and to start to bridge
the communities.
HADLEY WICKHAM:
Awesome.
We also had kind
of a few questions,
like, you're embedded inside
Google, which clearly, like,
uses a bunch of algorithms.
And sometimes those
outcomes are good.
And sometimes they're bad.
Like, how do you see
your role and kind
of shifting how Google
uses algorithms for good?
MARTIN WATTENBERG:
We like good algorithms.
[LAUGHS] And I think,
more importantly, I think,
in general, people want
to do the right thing.
And I think one of the
things that's important
is to give people tools to make
it sort of understandable what
to do.
One of the things that
is important, like, it
can be very hard to know.
Like, these things are
very complicated systems.
And the more tools that we
have to help us figure out,
OK, let's do this
rather than do that.
How do we make decisions
around them the better?
So we definitely view
ourselves as making tools
both for Google.
We open source that we want
I think for the whole world
as well.
HADLEY WICKHAM: Awesome.
Thank you, I had another
personal question,
which is, how long do
you spend coming up
with, like, humorous and
good acronyms for your--
[LAUGHS]
FERNANDA VIEGAS:
I didn't notice.
MARTIN WATTENBERG:
Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
You need to do more of that.
Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
HADLEY WICKHAM:
Let's see.
What else do we have?
Have you created any examples
to illustrate the intuition
behind adversarial images?
Yeah.
MARTIN WATTENBERG:
Between adversarial images?
Oh, OK, so no.
For a moment, I thought
you already said
generative adversarial network.
So we do have one of those--
something called GAN Lab.
But adversarial images are
super interesting and weird.
For those who may not
have heard of them,
it's this phenomenon
that you can
take an image that a computer
is correctly certain about.
Like, it's a picture of a
cat or a frog or something.
It for sure sees it as a cat.
You change the pixels
in a tiny amount
so that it's
imperceptible to a human.
And all of a
sudden, the computer
is certain it's like a
bathtub or something.
And at first, it
was seen as like,
some sort of weird one-off bug.
But what's been
clear is that it's
like a pervasive
thing that happens
across lots of classifiers.
I think one of the
reasons I don't
think we've created something
that it sort of helps
people understand it is that
the research community itself--
I don't think there's
a crisp explanation.
It's one of the
genuine mysteries.
There are some interesting
ideas about maybe this
has to do with the high
dimensional nature of the data.
And any imperfect
classifier might have these.
Or that, in fact, there
are important things
that a computer picks up
on in terms of texture
that the human eye
is just bad at.
But I don't know that there's
a final answer to that.
Therefore, it's
very hard to make
an easy crisp
visualization of it.
But it's a great
question, actually.
It's something
probably we should try.
HADLEY WICKHAM: Thanks.
I think we'll do
one last question.
So you've showed
a bunch of tools
today that you can
use in your browser.
Does the data ever
go to Google server?
Or can you use it with
like, confidential data,
like HIPAA-protected data?
FERNANDA VIEGAS:
So anything that's
available on Google Cloud,
you should be able to
use with your own data
and confidentiality for sure.
MARTIN WATTENBERG:
I mean, there is a
question about device--
on device versus off device.
And what I would say is rather
than giving a crisp answer
to that up here, I would
read carefully the fine print
of whichever tool.
But many of these things do, in
fact, keep the data on device.
FERNANDA VIEGAS:
There is a whole
other project we didn't
get to talk about today here.
But if you are
interested, tensorFlow.js
Is it brings machine
learning to your browser.
And one of the perks of
that, there is no install.
There's no download.
But one of the biggest
perks is privacy
because it runs all locally.
Nothing gets sent to any server.
We didn't have time to
talk about it today.
But it's definitely
worth checking out.
HADLEY WICKHAM:
Awesome.
Thank you.
So please join me in
thanking Fernanda and Martin.
[APPLAUSE]